[Music]
thank you
on this special edition of The Sky News
Daily podcast we take a look back at
some of the stories that shaped 2022 and
how they might shape our lives in the
future over five Plankton special
episodes we'll be covering politics
International Affairs economics climate
change episode 8 we're looking at the
Royal Family the end of the second
Elizabethan era what can be expected
from the reign of King Charles and you
know what we might have to mention Harry
and Megan as well as you can see we're
joined by Royal correspondent Rhiannon
Mills lovely to see you um before we get
into the long grass and all of this have
you ever known a year on the Royal beat
like it do you know what the last three
years have been quite extraordinary
um the death of Prince Philip everything
that's happened with the sussexes the
stories around prince Andrew it's been a
roller coaster over three years really
but I think at the start of every year
the royal family they always have their
calendar drilled down so you know kind
of the big events that are going to
happen and I think this was going to be
a year where things were meant to get
back to normal because we didn't have
the restrictions of covid so we thought
they'd be back out and about again doing
tours but yeah the the stories the
events that unfolded
um yeah many of us just could not
um predict and it's been extraordinary
well let's start with the Jubilee and
platinum Jubilee and I mean just in
terms of you know being in a job for any
length of time I mean her majesty was
from the moment that she that she a city
to the throne I mean she she did say she
was going to devote her life to Public
Service never never back away from it
and and she didn't absolutely it at the
start of the year because obviously the
Platinum Jubilee actually started in in
February with accession day so the
moment that her father died and and
that's always a slightly obviously
tricky time because she's obviously
wanted she wanted to kind of pay respect
to her father but but that's where the
kind of celebratory feel kind of began
and and at that time it felt fairly
low-key as it always does around
accession day I kept saying to people
look we need to remember that this is
the only monarch who has ever achieved
70 years on the throne this is quite a
remarkable Legacy it's a remarkable and
feat that she's achieved but I think
right from that accession day moment it
felt like the queen was going to use
this year to to Future proof the rest of
the institution and emphasize that this
wasn't just about her because I think
that was the extraordinary thing about
the queen this was never about her own
ego or her own kind of personal
fulfillment this was this was about
carrying out a role protecting an
institution that she was she was born
into and and so from accession day you
might remember that accession day
message where literally kind of the
WhatsApp group blew up like that we have
with all the Royal correspondence and
the palace when there was that message
saying yeah I want Camilla to be Queen
consort I'm like wow where's this come
from what was there then a feeling
because even back then there were there
were signs of the old age beginning to
catch up with that and of course the
loss of her husband was was a big factor
in that in that as well but was that
already at that point in the year a
beginning of the beginnings of a feeling
of the handing of the tour I think we've
had that for a few years so for example
with remembrance Sunday for a few years
now the now King has placed the Queen's
wreath on behalf of the nation so that's
kind of very subtly been happening but
now I think this year it no one was
afraid to really talk about it
I mean she was working all the way to
the end of course that photo of the
queen meeting the briefly prime minister
Les trust you know but even then there
were there were signs physical signs
that perhaps things were not were not
all great yeah I think if we go back to
the Platinum Jubilee
um that weekend there was so much chat
about how much exactly we'd see the
queen
um and she knew that the crowds had come
out to see her and so we had on the it's
unbelievable isn't it to think it was it
was this four-day event this four Day
celebration on the Thursday we had the
troop in the color she had she made two
balcony appearances the crowd went mad
when they saw her but after Thursday we
then thought that she was going to go to
a service at Saint Paul's on the Friday
she wasn't well enough to do that we
were told that she needed to rest she'd
also kind of started off some Beacon
Lighting on the Thursday night
and that again was that sense of do you
know what she is obviously trying to
really rally herself to do this
um but also you can't forget the that we
can't talk about Paddington Bear I can't
not talk about padding go on then my
goodness before we get into more summer
times
um I excuse the name dropping but I was
backstage at the Platinum Jubilee
concert with the likes of I don't know
Rod Stewart Queen Andrea Bocelli Jason
Donovan
absolutely the the big names and um I I
didn't get to watch this concert go out
and then all of a sudden on Twitter
everyone's going mad about this
Paddington Bear moment and um and I
watched it and look I can't be a bit of
a softy I watched it I was like oh my
goodness this is heartwarming and
anything was it a deep fake was it one
of these like deep fake queens and it
wasn't she had decided that for her
Platinum Jubilee she was again going to
completely catch us all out and um and I
just think it was her amazing sense of
humor really and and actually the family
didn't know about it I asked Camilla
about it on the flight back from Rwanda
after the Commonwealth heads government
meeting I was like did you know it was
coming she said no we didn't know it was
coming
um so yeah but we have to we have to
talk about about the end
so I was in our offices that are in the
center of London and
um I remember
I thought it was going to be a quiet
morning I remember the message coming
through from the palace around lunchtime
yeah 12 30 saying
um that doctors were concerned about the
Queen's health
and
um and then it was the next bit that
really set the alarm bells ringing for
me that the family were making their way
up to to Balmoral
and it was
I think it caught us all by surprise on
the Tuesday so just a couple of days
before I'd been in the rain in Balmoral
the queen had kind of
been doing that Handover of
um from one prime minister to the next
carried out that really important
constitutional role
and then on the on the Wednesday night
we've been told that she was on well so
couldn't carry out a privy council
meeting but that wasn't that unexpected
because those things were kind of
happening quite regularly then Thursday
this comes through and it was the fact
that doctors were concerned about her
health the family were heading in that
direction to Balmoral
it felt look for the eight years that
I've done the job it just felt
completely out of kilter from what you
would normally get from the royal family
and then
as the afternoon went on I have to say
Westminster went into a complete
meltdown of rumors and it was
um and when you're reporting on a story
like that look you want to be accurate
um there are no prizes for getting this
one wrong
and so it was trying to stay calm
um but keep people informed when there
is kind of a vacuum of information that
that's quite difficult
and then
um
yeah we
we were sort of alerted a couple of
minutes before
um before it was then announced by email
and
um the royal family website we knew that
that would go black and that there would
be some kind of announcement put on
there
and it was half past six but
throughout the afternoon it was just
this constant Rumor Mill of she's died
and Noah's reporting it
um for me
they were never going to make that
announcement until the family were there
in in Scotland and most of the family
were there Harry wasn't I I don't want
us to dwell too long on what happened
next because frankly you know the
country did have 10 days of national
mourning in the middle of you know a
cost of living crisis which some people
you know did see was was perhaps on the
excessive side we had the funeral I mean
what were your thoughts about that I
don't think we'll ever see that again no
I don't and look eight years I've
carried around a book of you know a
black book of notes sort of waiting for
this moment and I've always known the
choreography of what was going to happen
over that 10 days and I I was very clear
in my mind which I don't think some
people were that the moment that the
queen took her last breath we
immediately had a new king and for me it
was
it was always going to be fascinating to
watch how the palace handled that
that immense outpouring of grief and
people wanting to mourn the death of a
woman that they they clearly loved very
much some people not really sure why
they felt that connection because they'd
never met her but but really wanted to
mark that moment and then you kind of
mix that with the Trumpets on Ferrari
court at St James's welcome in the new
king how do you how do you get the
balance right between those two emotions
and actually I think the palace they
played it perfectly but also I was
within the planning that there was
there were plans for these huge queues
of people to come and see the queen
lying in state and I was thinking really
is that going to happen this isn't this
isn't the 1950s this isn't when her
father died we live in a much less
deferential age would people really come
out and and they really did they did but
I will just to play a devil's advocate
yeah as a statistically significant
share of the overall population the cues
at Westminster were not I'm afraid
I still think there is something to take
away from the fact that some people are
queuing for
15 hours but some people some others not
everybody others who work in our
industry and perhaps and perhaps jump
the cube but that that does give us an
opportunity to kind of talk about the
next stage the end with the end of the
the second Elizabethan era we now have
our new King King Charles uh we will be
he will be Crohn's next year but what
are his priorities what are we learning
about the way in which his Royal
household might be different from that
of his mother
look we can't get away from the fact
that
not everyone has always warmed to the
idea of having a King Charles
and and actually I thought there would
be more protest and more complaint about
well hang on a minute we don't get to
choose this man why why'd he just step
into that role and there hasn't been and
and actually I think what's happened
kind of down the road from Buckingham
Palace at number 10 has kind of been
quite helpful really yeah at a time when
you've got Prime Ministers coming and
going a man who has been here for 70
years actually feels like a sense of
continuity in some ways
um and I've been out and about with him
various engagements up and down the
country and what's been really striking
is how people they want to touch him
like he's right what do you mean sorry
for Cutie yes really peculiar in a way
that we never would have seen with the
Queen the kiss there touching his hand
they're kissing him
encouraging it at the very least it's
very close he's very close and he's and
and there's this warmth
um and I think people are connecting
with that look
you can't get away from the criticisms
that the royal family have faced
recently and for example the domestic
violence reception that was held at
Buckingham Palace and then the racism
allegations that came out of that
um
you have a new Reign which is starting
in a completely different
phase of life and and people's opinions
a much more polarized than the start of
the Queen's Reign because that's what
he's jumping into there is a constant
though isn't it and it is Camilla I mean
how important has she been how important
will she be to his Reign which of course
will not be as long as his mother
yeah hugely important and um
it's amazing isn't it really to think
that this is a woman who was
widely hated ostracized
um
held up as kind of
the the woman that drove Diana away
um actually when you watch them together
they are they're a brilliant team they
are a brilliant working team she does
soften him they do laugh a lot together
um and I think especially during that
time after the queen died
she was like remember the one of the pen
incidents where
he was filmed shouting at this pen
because it was leaking and it was
Camilla who was there I've tried to calm
down the situation and I think that's
definitely what she does for him but
also she's
like she's been very clear on her
wanting to do this work around domestic
violence and and use her platform and
has been able to kind of come out and be
more more outspoken about that but we
are also already seeing signs of the
next hand over and William and Keats
have been so much more prominent
although you know they have had a couple
of dodgy missteps over the past 12
months yeah yeah
yeah I was thinking about it the
Caribbean tour oh my goodness that seems
like
years ago but but no that was the start
of this year where they went on this
Caribbean tour to Belize Jamaica and the
Bahamas and um yeah many came away from
it saying that was an absolute disaster
I'm not sure it was the complete
disaster that everyone
portrayed as actually I was there
um interviewed various people in all of
those countries and no they weren't they
weren't wall-to-wall protests
um but it did show we're in it we are in
a new era and
um and when it comes to addressing those
issues around
diversity inclusivity racism
that is what they are they are sort of
wading into now and and they can't they
can't avoid it and I don't think they
are trying to avoid it really I think
the king like in the days after the
queen died he had this um this meeting
of
multi-faith leaders where he said how
diversity is is one of the things that
he he sees as his key role to promote it
and and also his his address to the
nation it was it it felt very inclusive
um but
if they are to modernize uh the monarchy
there is a there is a big task ahead of
them and indeed that will be something
that we will be discussing uh after the
break uh viewed through the prism of
guess who Harry and Megan
[Music]
uh welcome back to this special edition
of this guy News Daily podcast our role
correspondent Rhiannon Mills is here
taking us through at 2022 for the the
house of Windsor and look I wonder if
you can just remind us
what was the Susan Hussey incident
because it it plays into what we're
about to talk to talk to the Harry and
Megan documentary Series yeah so you had
a um
domestic violence reception at
Buckingham Palace which was being billed
as a massive moment for Camilla who we
know has been so passionate about his
cause
um she had invited kind of leading
voices in that space and yet a couple of
days later it was completely
overshadowed by the fact that one of
those domestic violence campaigners
um claimed that she had been approached
by a lady in waiting or a member of the
royal household and been questioned
about her ethnicity
um it absolutely blew up understandably
completely blew up for them
um and what I think was most telling was
how quickly the palace responded
and specifically I mean William you know
this is his godmother wasn't it I mean
he he called I can't remember the
physiology used but it was basically
along the lines of this is important you
have to put it in the context they were
flying to America for
their first overseas trip for a while
their first to America since 2014 and
for his Earth shot prize so from a
strategic perspective shutting trying to
shut down that story was obviously going
to be very important
but his spokesperson
was kind of making it very clear that he
did not accept what had happened this
was wrong and was going to call that out
and for me that was what was so striking
about that incident was I think in the
past
under the queen we would not necessarily
have seen them deal with it with the
speed sure it did but but wasn't wasn't
the speed in part in large part because
you know in essence it confront that
which Meghan Markle had said in that
interview to Oprah Winfrey that there
was racism in the Royal household yeah
and the the
that was so toxic
um when Megan made those allegations
about the royal family and it's hung
over them it's hung over everything that
they've done it's been repeated in the
documentary hasn't it yeah it's been
repeated in documentary it um when when
William and Kate went to the Caribbean
um it was it was being used then for
people who were who were saying oh they
don't get it they don't get the issue
around slavery oh and Megan would know
that because she says they're racist
um so yeah I think they had to it was
out of necessity however if the queen
was still around would we have seen them
react with that speed I'm not sure that
we would have done because
Susan Hussey had been her devoted lady
and waiting for for a very long time
um now the palace are delighted that
both parties have got together and have
had this meaningful discussion
um
shouldn't have happened in the first
place no have the palace been enough on
the front foot to tell us what they are
doing when it comes to addition and like
addressing those issues internally not
necessarily
but just in terms of of the the negative
impact that the documentary clearly has
had and the kind of the more detailed
allegations that emerged in the latest
the the later episodes I I do wonder I
mean is there a relationship
that is capable of being saved and I'm
not just talking about Charles and Harry
but William and Harry I mean they're
Brothers for goodness sakes
look that just watching the six hours
felt exhausted exhausting and um and I
just came away from it thinking yes okay
financially they've done very well out
of it but I I
don't really know what Harry and Megan
have necessarily achieved from it really
no
always been such divisive figures anyway
some people love them other people
despise them will it have shifted the
dial for anyone on that Spectrum I don't
think so I think it's just ramped up
both sides I kind of see it every time I
write anything about this story yeah the
level of abuse that I get
is is off the charts compared to
anything else that I write about when it
comes to the royal family
um
why did Harry
I wrote the other day Harry it feels
like he is a prince who are telling his
side of the fairy tale has basically
fed the Beast that he is trying to slay
he has fed the Tabloid press with all
the stories that they wanted about him
falling out with William about him
falling out with his father I don't know
why he had to go in that direction but
but I I I I completely hear you I
completely get it do you then think that
Buckingham Palace Charles that for 2023
dealing with Harry and Megan you know
perhaps bringing them back and thought
that is anywhere close to a priority for
them I mean what are they looking to do
in 2023 apart from ensure that Andrew
never gives another interview
I think they'll want to guarantee that
for a very long time
um
look you've got the coronation coming up
so already people are talking about will
they get an invitation to the coronation
or not we'll get an invite to my own way
Prince Philip's funeral as well
to people within the palace this is why
there's a sense of weariness and also a
sense of sadness I speak yeah there
probably is a sense of anger as well
they've done this Netflix series
um
efforts were made to make them feel
included around the Queens
death
um Charles in his address to the nation
talked about the Queens an erring
ability to see the good in everyone and
that week around her death it felt like
they were saying look
we're going to put everything to one
side and we're all going to be a united
front as a family
and then Harry and Megan have done this
and I think there is a sense of sadness
about it
but also someone at the palace said to
me the other day in some ways the family
are now being Guided by a mantra that
the queen was always Guided by which was
don't look at your feet look to the
horizon
and
the problem the problem with that is
what is coming over the horizon Harry's
book
in January why do I get the the
impression Rhiannon that 2023 is going
to be a very very busy year for you look
thank you so much for taking us through
at 2022 and of course any number of
those little individual stories that
Rhiannon and I have been covering we
have covered on the podcast you can
listen to those where you discovered
this one also at the same time our other
end of year podcasts are on the on well
on economics Politics the climate change
and everything else you can find those
as well but from me thanks for joining
us
[Music]